david we haven't spoken to you since the
first of 22 lawsuits has filed against
desean watson do you expect him to be
at
mini camp or otas
uh we have nothing to say about that
situation at this time
uh kyle and ownership a few weeks back
uh
indicated about
how our organization feels about the
situation i think when nick was on not
long ago we mentioned that
he also mentioned that uh the legal
process is in effect right now and we're
gonna we're gonna respect that and and
gonna go from there
but do you expect to see him in this
offseason at all like regardless of
legal issues i have nothing to say about
that at this time
david culley from over the weekend at
rookie mini camp talking about desean
watson or more accurately not talking
about desean watson when we last heard
from him podcast quotes had emerged
where he for the first time seemed to
open the door on the possibility of a
trade then he showed up for the press
conference not long after those quotes
emerged and somebody apparently had
gotten to him
and told him to revert to the we're not
trading desean watson playbook but look
chris this isn't surprising now the
texans are watching and waiting and
hoping at some level that these cases do
get resolved because
although i've heard that some teams are
trying to engage the texans now with
these lawsuits pending if that's true
and i don't know that it is
i think the texans are resisting
engaging in any discussions now because
with those lawsuits the value
in trade is necessarily lower than if
the lawsuits get resolved and there's
definitely
an effort
to try to get the cases resolved and
what we saw last week in the back and
forth between tony busby who represents
the 22 women and rusty hardin who
represents deshaun watson that's
something that emerged once they had
tried
to resolve the cases and the big
sticking point and this turns everything
on its head from what we usually see the
big sticking point is rusty harden
on behalf of deshawn watson wants no
confidentiality no one to be muzzled in
any way about the amount of the
settlement any of the facts you can talk
about at all you want
the lawyer for the plaintiffs is the one
who according to hardin
wants
everything to be confidential and and
that's where they reach their impasse
and that's why this isn't done and
it's unclear whether or not they can get
past that and if they don't the cases
have to go forward i i mean yes i i
would think at base level right i mean
of course houston wants all things
settled i mean yes so they can move on
whether that's they want to keep desean
watson or like you said get the the ball
rolling on a trade offer to where yeah
i'm sure teams are keeping their eye on
this situation and like you know to what
you were saying a little mike yeah the
value of the trade is certainly down
right as of right now but like there's i
can't even imagine a team making a legit
trade-off or being aggressive when you
don't know how this is going to play out
at this moment so that's where to me
it's kind of a a
dead point and we just got to let it
play out and see where it goes but like
i don't expect to hear houston make any
comments about desean watson at this
point right i mean am i wrong to think
like they don't want to be liable to
anything here as far as just making any
comment on the situation
to maybe now us read into that to like
oh they were hoping this happens or this
happens and and that's where they can be
liable at some point so i would expect
them to say hush hush about this
i don't know if there's anything they'd
be liable for in that sense it just
makes no sense for them to say anything
for
overall best interest of the team we
talked about the best interest of the
bears last segment best interest of the
texans say nothing wait and hope that
these cases get resolved so that then
they can move on from deshaun watson
because i think at this point the minute
they are resolved that's when
the
the auction for the contract begins and
and if the cases do get resolved i think
it does potentially put the texans in
line to get a significant return because
even though there's a very strong
likelihood watson will be suspended by
the league even if all the cases are
resolved today yeah teams are willing to
take him on yes knowing that that vague
reality is out there get it over with
2021 season four games six games eight
games that's kind of the number that
that's bouncing around although no one
really knows what's going to happen
that's the estimate
uh and then you move forward you have to
sean watson for the next 10 maybe 15
years yeah if it all works out well and
you keep him happy contractually and he
plays well so there will be teams that
are interested there are teams that are
interested and and again i don't know
that this is true but there's definitely
some scuttle but
the teams are even now trying to engage
the texans and they're not being
responsive and i think the easy
explanation is there's no reason to be
now you don't want to start a
conversation
in a universe where the lawsuits drag
down what the trade value is let's just
wait until the cases are over if they
can be resolved and i still think
there's a pathway to a resolution chris
look they've got to worry about
the criminal investigation that could
morph into a prosecution although it's
going to be very hard to prove anything
beyond a reasonable doubt they've also
got to worry about the nfl the nfl is
watching everything that's being said
everything that's being done and that's
one of the reasons chris that i firmly
believe
rusty harden wants no confidentiality to
attach to any of these settlements they
want to do nothing that will frustrate
the efforts of the nfl to get to the
bottom of this to get to the truth
they're comfortable with that and they
don't want to be perceived as hiding
anything yeah i mean i mean that makes
sense yes i i mean he's already been
taken you know through the wash as far
as like deshawn watson's concerned it's
all out there so he's probably at this
point like yeah no i i mean i i want
them to be held you know to their word
and things like that i i get that you
know and mike i'm with you
i know there's teams that are still
watson's very much on their radar still
and yeah it's weird i get it but when
you're definitely one of the five best
players in the nfl yeah you can have
these type of circumstances and teams
know you're going to get suspended and
they're still going to want you on their
team because desean watson's a franchise
superstar quarterback who just started
the prime of his career and that means
he's got like 10 years left of really
good football and so teams are going to
be interested in that no matter what
really unless something really crazy got
thrown out here and just it was a no no
win situation but i fully expect at some
point there to be a market for him
there's currently no reason to think
he's never going to play football again
would he play this year who knows
next year if these cases aren't resolved
who knows but at some point he's going
to be back and he plays a position where
you can play into your 40s now well into
your 40s as we see with tom brady and
and he's established himself desean
watson has is one of the best in the
game so he'll be playing for somebody at
some point barring something
very unexpected and basically shocking
at this point that would end his career
for good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports